Kenya Moore is officially a mom
fabulous Gone with the Wind fabulous The
Real Housewives of Atlanta star
announced that she and her hubby Mark
Daly were expecting their first child
together in April on the season 10
reunion any word of a baby twirl well he
or she would be named twirl for sure
that's my dog's name right yes we will
definitely be welcoming a boy or girl in
late this year Kenya who was due around
Thanksgiving took to Instagram in
October to reveal that she was suffering
from a condition called preeclampsia
which is the result of persistent high
blood pressure
Kenya posted this pic of her swollen
feet writing quote I gained 17 pounds in
one week due to severe swelling and
water retention she later wrote in her
insta story quote I will have to deliver
hashtag baby daily early but I'm being
closely monitored to determine when a
few weeks earlier the reality star
revealed that after six seasons on the
Bravo reality series she decided to quit
the show I make for interesting TV but
on October 25th she was spotted filming
with her cast mate Cynthia Bailey stay
tuned to figure out ET sat down with
another member of the show kandi Burruss
who opened up about the 47 year old
leaving to focus on having a healthy
pregnancy but promises fans will get an
on-screen update from Kenya are we gonna
get to see any of Kenya's journey on the
show this year who does she pop up at
all well she does pop up okay she does
pop up once to my begging of course I
was probably one of the most
disappointing feet of everybody that she
wasn't gonna be with us this year but I
feel like it was great for her to be
able to enjoy her pregnancy and I you
know go back and forth with people and
all of that stuff
so it's great for her to have a healthy
pregnancy but I just was like you know
Kenya people got to see at least one and
so I kind of twisted her arm she is
gonna be there and while Kenya will only
make the one appearance on season 11
kandi says there's always hope for a
full-time return in season 12 I feel
like the you know the Bravo family
wouldn't mind her being back everything
happens for a reason this was a time
that she needed to focus on her baby
yeah you know to me and being healthy
that's what it for me you know that's
why things happen the way they happen
but do I feel like she should be back or
that she would be back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]